ich habe letztens mit meinen Freunden
gefrühstückt und habe viel zu viele
Brötchen gekauft
deshalb habe ich mich gefragt was ich
mit ihnen anfangen soll
und ich dachte mir ich mache
Semmelbrösel
und das Beste was man mit Semmelbröseln
machen kann ist ein Wiener Schnitzel
aber dafür müssen die Brötchen erstmal
trocken werden
Schnitzel war als Kind mein absolutes
Lieblingsessen und heute liebe ich noch
genauso sehr
ich kenne glaube ich niemanden der
Schnitzel nicht mag
ist ein bisschen so wie mit Pizza
und warum sollte man das Gericht dass
man so gerne mag nicht auch einfach mal
richtig feiern
nicht richtig Zeit nehmen und
alles einfach mal selbst machen
das Gericht ein bisschen besser
verstehen
das machen wir heute
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch ich war mal
in Wien und habe dort nichts anderes
getan als das beste Wiener Schnitzel zu
suchen
deshalb glaubt mir wenn ich sage dass
ich das Thema ernst nehme
und mir richtig Mühe geben werde
und die gleiche Sorgfalt hat auch unser
Kartoffelsalat verdient
das Kochen machte meiner neuen Küche
einfach noch mehr Spaß und ich freue
mich auf jedes Video das wir drehen
manchmal gehe ich extra ins Büro einfach
nur um in der neuen Küche zu kochen und
ich freue mich so sehr dass das erst der
Anfang ist von den Geschichten die
dieser neue Ort schreiben wird
[Musik]
aber ey ihr werdet sehr mit mir erleben
können
ich bin auch wirklich einfach sehr
dankbar dass ich es geschafft habe
irgendwie noch mehr Freude zu finden als
ich sowieso schon hatte
dass kein Ende in Sicht ist bei diesen
ganzen Thema bei dieser Reise und
auch weil ich mich einfach freue auf das
was kommt
ich meine ich bin jetzt bald mit Eric
für zwei Wochen in Amerika
wir reisen dort rum natürlich wieder nur
mit Essen im Kopf
werden probieren die bestmöglichen
Videos für euch zu drehen
ich habe diese wunderschöne neue Küche
das fühlt sich schon manchmal so real an
das ist irgendwie
so gut ist alles
deshalb möchte ich die Gelegenheit
einfach noch mal nutzen um auch mal
Danke zu sagen
danke dass ihr euch die Videos anschaut
[Musik]
aber vergessen wir das wichtigste nicht
das Kochen
für mich ist diese Art und Weise zu
kochen der genau Gegenentwurf zu dem was
ich meistens in meinem Alltag habe
[Musik]
schnelle Gerichte Fast Food
bestelltes Essen
wenn man sich so viel Zeit nimmt dann
macht man das Gericht von einer
Nebensache zu einer absoluten Hauptsache
[Musik]
das ist fast so ein bisschen als würde
man den Sternerestaurant gehen
wo man sich einfach nur darauf
konzentriert wie alles schmeckt
wie alles aussieht
die die einzelnen Bestandteile
zusammenkommen
nur dass man es einfach selbst machen
kann
ohne Sternekoch sein zu müssen
ich mache das auch alles zum ersten mal
so ich habe noch nie diesen
Kartoffelsalat gemacht aber wenn man
sich so viel Zeit nimmt dann kann man
eigentlich gar nichts falsch machen
falls ihr euch fragt was ich gerade
mache ich mache das Dressing für den
Kartoffelsalat
daran kommt nichts anderes als Brühe
Rotweinessig Senf rote Zwiebeln und
Petersilie
das ganze ist über Nacht durchgezogen
und wir können unsere Kartoffeln
schneiden
etwas Sonnenblumenöl darüber
wir mischen das Ganze durch
[Musik]
und das Dressing ist jetzt bereit in
unsere Kartoffeln einzuziehen
ich liebe diesen Kräutergarten in meiner
neuen Küche
in meiner alten muss ich immer auf den
Balkon und dort die Kräuter holen und
hier habe ich einfach direkt vor mir
das Ganze gut abdecken
wirklich gut abdecken
[Musik]
und wir sehen das erst wieder wenn unser
Schnitzel fertig ist
gute Sachen brauchen einfach Zeit
bei Kaffee ist das genauso
entweder du hast mit einem
knopfdruckenden soliden Kaffee
oder du machst jeden Arbeitsschutz
selbst
ich würde immer lieber einen solchen als
10 andere trinken
[Musik]
ich habe noch nie Preise bei Marmelade
gemacht aber ich habe auch generell noch
nie Marmelade gemacht deshalb war ich
überrascht wie einfach das geht
ich habe auf dem Markt eineinhalb Kilo
Preise wären gekauft die müssen wir
einfach nur waschen
[Musik]
die Hälfte an Zucker dazugeben
und das ganze kochen das war's
ich habe das Gefühl jetzt schon richtig
viel gelernt zu haben
[Musik]
die Vorbereitungen sind getroffen
aber etwas fehlt noch
unser Schnitzel
[Musik]
die selbstgemachten Semmelbrösel riechen
so viel besser als gekaufte
wir klopfen unser Schnitzel
geben Butterschmalz in den Topf
[Musik]
und wir schicken unser Schnitzel durch
die panierstraße
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der wahrscheinlich
wichtigste Schritt wir müssen unser
Schnitzel soufflieren
durch die ständigen Bewegungen entstehen
diese knusprigen Bläschen
[Musik]
der typische Look von einem richtig
guten Schnitzel
die Zitrone darf nicht fehlen
und wir richten an
[Musik]
raus aus der Magie rein in die Realität
guckt es euch an es waren viele Stunden
Arbeit 100 um genau zu sein aber wie so
oft bereue ich gar nichts es war eine
unfassbar beruhigende angenehme
Erfahrung und das Endprodukt war einfach
nur lecker also ich muss wirklich sagen
hier seht ihr es noch der Crunch
er ist real er ist real ich bin stolz
auf unserer Ergebnis und habe wie immer
sehr viel Spaß gehabt da vorne sitzen
ganz viele hungrige Mäuler die gerne
versorgt werden wollen deshalb mache ich
jetzt genau das hier auf der Seite ist
ein für euch empfohlenes Video da könnt
ihr gerne drauf klicken wenn ihr Lust
auf mehr bekommen habt ich habe auch
noch ein paar von diesen 100 Stunden
Videos und ja lasst gerne ein Abo da und
klickt die Glocke das würde mich sehr
freuen weil das hat so viel Spaß gemacht
dass ich das bestimmt noch mal mache
okay mach's gut bis dahin und ciao